ots pessoal de quem fala andar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um biênio e os
trabalhos de que um vídeo de forte na
então aí olha mas vocês não pensa em
buscar fortunati porque eu não vou ver o
que vou fazer é dançar os dentes do
fortunato na vida real que muita gente
já fez mas eu vou fazer forma de frente
como é que vai lançar o quanto vocês
promoção até eu vou lançar os dados do
fortuna haiti música que leve mais
acidente pode dar para uma tragédia
também pode mudar eu vou cair
certamentes importante foi só até o fim
pessoal e muito obrigada epic games por
patrocinar este vídeo muito obrigado por
patrocinar nós só que ele queime o que
pra quem não sabe o que é forte no haiti
que o youtube do mundo projeto agente
gol é fortalecer um jogo beckham ou seja
tipo jogadores contra o jogador sempre é
basicamente entre 16 jogadores dentro de
campo e tudo em uma batalha para ver
quem ganha com certeza dos gastos que eu
saí mas porque ainda não chegou lá
embaixo na descrição vocês podem baixar
lá eu agradeci e pequenos assim também
fica contente porque ao tomar outro
funcionário e sim só deixarem pelo meu
link é eu fui muito sexual vashem no
link vocês nunca jogaram inclusive já
ajuda aqui perto no telemóvel e tudo vou
jogar um pouquinho só pra vocês verem
mas como é esse processo jogou eu vou
explicar para que vocês têm um campo
gigante entre um avião um de seis
jogadores estão lá dentro pois os seus
jogadores
quando você está lá embaixo vocês têm
que apanhar todos os cursos que
conseguirem tipo armas balas mas o que a
granada não é muita coisa e com isso
vocês podem perguntar os vossos inimigos
são jogadores que também estão lá
embaixo com vocês e não é 99 população
gosta né
mas basicamente é isso pessoal vocês
podem baixar com hulk que está na
descrição podem ficar à vontade o jogo é
completamente gratuito e vocês podem
ficar no ps e ps 4 no telemóvel nexus
box pode estar no microondas no
frigorífico não podem jogar em todas as
plataformas com a faixa favorita mesmo
que o telemóvel topo da página nem tudo
lá é muito bom e outra coisa pessoal que
o desenrolar agora é que muita gente viu
no último vídeo forte no haiti que já
foi a algum tempo vocês podem destinar
no formato de jogar comigo e adicionando
o meu eo elenco é dar caiu que vai
perceber que é só ensinar em lei podem
ficar comigo claro que não posso jogar
com toda a gente e disse nem lápis
quiserem que eu faça um vídeo dedicado
chuva mesmo pra vocês verem as linhas
que outras linhas de cuidados pessoas
comentarem esta for tahiti bora lá então
as danças música
e já sabe sua longa descrição baixem a
bola pessoal já temos aqui na sala de
estar colando e com o nosso se quente
elétrico vejam só como eu ainda funciona
é porque já não anda muito tempo que já
não sendo a festa só tem nada do
treinador mas para lá pessoal como vocês
puderam ver está em cima do bolo é muito
difícil fazer qualquer movimento que
seja tipo só lá na frente e para trás o
imaginam a segunda 10 a 15 mil m
possível dizer que gostaria de ir para
lá só vamos pensar em mudanças do
fortunato já tinha aqui no pc e aí já
com que um vídeo aos 45 dessas de
fortunati na vida real comparação vamos
ver se vamos tentar fazer igual mas não
me importo vai dar muita voz de servir
para só o primeiro a doença 321 vai um
pouco o meu deus acima dessa chama isso
aqui que esta vai ser complicado
afinal esse não é o ok final da rua otto
questão mas não é recente
esta é muito complicada muito próxima
das eleições no próprio próximas cinco
épocas
[Música]
a próxima é esse gancho por lei e não
chove
a regra é fácil suportar os custos do
processo é pedaço de quem não estava
aqui acho que não vai ser fácil
o cara certo para o próximo ano essa é
todos homens
[Música]
essa é muito cuidado porque senão dar um
sim não ó ó ó comunicado
como é essa
o ato cansado é muito complicado dançar
em cima do futebol mexe eu vou descansar
um pouco e vou tentar fazer um pouco de
frio está ela que na sala
essa casa tem que fazer isso dentro de
mim lá para lá agora vai ser tudo de
pessoas que se infectaram vamos lá
continuar a dançar porque eu já vi tudo
muito treinando então quanto à próxima
[Música]
fase
o que é isso não é essa mas é essa bola
não sabe que a gente faça mais próxima
só você ver que a próxima fase
complicada
[Música]
[Risadas]
o rum a água
[Música]
e esses jogos para fazer e se não gostar
daquele período extenso do porto no
haiti já sabem se não for inscrito no
canal em escrever sem muito mais que
também por causa do estado fiquem mais
se aproximar
[Música]